le seul continent qui peut être étiqueté
coville négatif et sans doute
l'antarctique le corona virus est
partout de la tchoukotka aux quatre
aucun du groenland à l'île de pâques
la mode est partout la même où que vous
regardiez tout le monde portent des
masques et des gants et le parfum numéro
un et le désinfectant pour les mains
c'est une journée sans fin avec des
portes closes derrière lesquelles les
gens continuent de travailler du mieux
qu'ils peuvent
ce film a pour sujet ceux dont le
travail consiste à observer et filmé il
s'agit de nos collègues des producteurs
et cadreurs qui nous aide à réaliser nos
documentaires partout dans le monde et
comme vous l'imaginez je vais devoir
faire ce film sans sortir de chez moi
à bientôt ciao
[Musique]
le virus est l'ennemi de la révolution
au chili l'épidémie a mis un terme aux
manifestations qui faisait rage depuis
octobre dernier
j'appelle oleg kassine ski qui vit
depuis de nombreuses années et qui nous
a souvent aidé à organiser des tournages
à travers l'amérique latine je pense
qu'au chili la situation et tragi
comique car pour le gouvernement actuel
la pandémie de coronavirus est la
meilleure chose qui pouvait arriver
les manifestations ont commencé l'année
dernière le 18 octobre
nous allons sur la place d'italie
son nom officiel est la place baquet
dang khanh la place centrale de santiago
a été occupé par des manifestants toutes
les nuits ils contrôlaient la majeure
partie de la ville
le gouvernement n'a répondu que par des
représailles
ils tiraient dans les yeux des
manifestants et ainsi de suite des
choses horribles ont eu lieu il ya
aujourd'hui des centaines de prisonniers
politiques dans le pays
il ya trois jours le président chilien
s'est illustré en se rendant à
l'épicentre désormais déserté des
manifestations il s'y est arrêté pour
une séance photo au milieu de la place
en souriant triomphalement qu'on ait des
pv d'hitler
aussi mec vient il faut désinfecter
après ce fils de aller mais c'est vrai
il ya eu des manifestations dans notre
quartier les gens pillaient des
supermarchés des banques sous le cas ces
dédales les arrachaient pour les jeter
sur la police tout le mur ont été
couverts de graffitis il barricadé les
rues avec des poubelles et maintenant
quand vous sortez dans la rue vous voyez
des gens qui laissent des sacs poubelles
sur le trottoir
nous avions beaucoup de sans abri ici
même avant tout ça et maintenant il y en
a vraiment beaucoup
ils traînent dans les rues déchire ses
sacs et puis tout reste dans la rue olga
est une ancienne collègue
il y a deux ans elle s'est mariée avec
un chilien comme la plupart des
habitants de santiago son mari et elle
même ont peur d'être contaminé par ce
qu'ils savent que les cliniques
publiques sont débordés et qui n'ont pas
les moyens de se faire soigner dans un
hôpital privé nous amener antilles sont
le virus avec ce liquide
il contient entre 5 et 10 % d'eau
chlorée et de liquide vaisselle
pourquoi ça ce que les produits de
dégraissage désintègre de virus
c'est une particule contenant de la
graisse qui protège la rn à ce jour
environ 50 mille tests ont été effectués
dans le pays
le test est gratuit mais pour le passé
il faut faire la queue 24 heures devant
un établissement de santé publique
seules les entreprises privées ont des
ambulances aux chiffres du quartier mais
son chef scout et malheureusement la
semaine dernière un jeune homme de 34
ans est décédé des suites du coronavirus
l'a contacté une clinique plusieurs fois
mais il ne pouvait pas le prendre en
charge
à cause du trop grand nombre de patients
les autorités ne font qu improvisé
ainsi les entreprises ont été autorisés
à cesser de payer les salaires pendant
la crise et a prétendument pour sauver
des emplois
on y est
[Musique]
il a fallu des dizaines de milliers
d'années à l'humanité pour atteindre
l'île de pâques le virus y est arrivé en
quelques mois seulement
bonjour de l'autre bout du monde je
m'appelle sebastian en ce moment nous
sommes dans une période où le
gouvernement a tenté de lever le
confinement qui a été prolongée jusqu'au
il pensait que nous n'avions pas autant
de cas malgré le fait qu'il y a deux
jours nous avons appris qu'il y avait
encore 120 personnes potentiellement
affectés parce qu'ils avaient été en
contact avec cinq personnes dont les
tests ont été envoyés à santiago et se
sont révélés positifs
il ne dispose que de trois appareils
respiratoires artificiel pour près de
10000 habitants
c'est le point le plus délicat est comme
gelée déjà dit nous devons remplacer la
situation actuelle dans le contexte
prendre en compte l'histoire de catry
similaires comme la variole et d'autres
épidémies que lille a traversé et qui
ont coûté très cher à notre population
[Musique]
le coc vide 19 s'est même propagé aux
tribus indiennes isolé d'amazonie sur
lesquelles notre chaîne a fait un film
avec l'aide de karim il a invité le
neurologue marcus onorato à se joindre à
notre conversation avant le confinement
il s'y rendait chaque semaine pour voir
ses patients la maladie mettra plus de
temps à arriver dans les régions
éloignées comme celle des tribus
indigènes
cependant il ya déjà eu un mort dans la
tribu yanomami mardi dernier et puisque
l'immunité des populations autochtones
est faible nous courons le risque de
voir disparaître l'ensemble des
populations autochtones les districts de
soins de santé indigène tentent de
s'adapter en réduisant autant que
possible le nombre de personnes qui
accèdent aux tribus pour réduire les
risques de contamination pour cette
raison de nouvelles restrictions sont
appliquées à certains services
y at il encore des médecins qui
travaillent avec les populations
autochtones
c'est maza oui mais la majorité des
tribus ont désormais accès aux premiers
soins 100 visites périodiques de
médecins au milieu de l'interview il
s'est avéré qu'il y avait une urgence au
domicile de karim il attendait un
médecin est il arrivé à ton fils as tu
essayé de savoir ce qui lui est arrivé
penses tu lui faire faire passer un test
du coronavirus monde à chaque poste
vous savez vu la situation dans notre
pays
il a été recommandé de rester chez soi
même si vous avez des symptômes et ils
tous fort depuis deux semaines et là il
a vraiment de la fièvre
je pense donc que je vais appeler un
médecin aujourd'hui
le brésil est en récession depuis
quelques années et la pandémie a aggravé
la situation
les gens ont exigé que le gouvernement
prenne des mesures urgentes pour freiner
l'épidémie et soutenir financièrement la
population mais la seule chose qu'ils
ont reçu c'est le confinement
comme partout dans le monde les
principaux foyers de l'épidémie sont les
grandes villes rio de janeiro et sao
paulo
mais le virus s'est également propagée
partout dans le reste du pays
être disciplinés ce n'est pas pour les
brésiliens selon karim il se trouve
qu'en ce moment l'endroit le plus sûr au
brésil ce sont les favelas ce les
dealers donc a pointé leurs armes sur
les gens et dire
rentrez chez vous n'allez nulle part si
quelqu'un a besoin de nourriture nous en
apporterons et ils le font leurs
affaires en dépendent
ils ne veulent pas que leur petit avion
comme il appelle les garçons qui livre
la drogue tombe malade
ils ne permettent pas aux gens de se
réunir pour boire un verre ou quoi que
ce soit ils disent rester à la maison on
s'occupe de tout tout est bien organisé
chez eux
la mairie de rio de janeiro par exemple
allouer quelques hôtels fils sont vides
à l'heure actuelle ils ont lancé deux
programmes
il y héberge des médecins et des
infirmiers à un prix avantageux pour
qu'il n'ait pas à faire des aller retour
chez eux et mettre leurs familles en
danger
il ya aussi un programme pour les
retraités
on propose aux personnes âgées
d'emménager gratuitement dans les hôtels
3 4 5 étoiles mais les gens ne quittent
pas les favelas ce il propose des
chambres d'hôtel avec petit déjeuner
déjeuner et dîner gratuit à toute
personne âgée de plus de 65 ans pourquoi
les gens ne quittent pas les favelas
tout d'abord les brésiliens et en
particulier les personnes âgées sont
très attachés à leur famille au brésil
jusqu'à 20 personnes vivent généralement
dans un même foyer
vingt personnes dans une maison c'est
courant ici ils aiment vivre ensemble et
personne ne veut aller dans le centre
ville de rio quitter les favelas ce ils
vous répondront qu'il s'y sent bien
si vous leur demandez
l'équateur a été le pays d'amérique
latine le plus touché sa plus grande
ville guayaquil en a beaucoup souffert
guayaquil les gens ont commencé à mourir
en grand nombre à cause du coronavirus
cela a été confirmé dans de nombreux
salons funéraires le personnel a
simplement refusé de venir travailler
par peur d'être contaminés la ville
était paralysée il n'y avait personne
pour enterrer les morts les cadavres
gisaient dans les rues
certaines familles on gardait des corps
dans leur appartement pendant 24 48
heures ou plus et nous parlons de
conditions climatiques tropicales avec
des températures au dessus de 32 35
degrés
l'administration de la ville a commencé
à donner des cercueils en carton gratuit
parce qu'il y à une pénurie de cercueils
dans la ville oleg m'a conseillé
d'entrer en contact avec un équatorien
célèbre ces choses arrivent toujours au
pire moment possible lors des entretiens
les plus importants c'était comme si des
coups de feu étaient tirés derrière mon
dos la pièce commençait à être rempli de
fumée il y à un bruit insupportable dans
la pièce c'était à cause des enfants
ils sont partis de la cuisine et il
préparait le dîner laissant une poêle
sans surveillance mais ce n'est par one
xvi journalistes analystes et ancien
guérillero et prisonnier politique de
l'organisation radicale de gauche alfaro
bébé carraro qui risque d'être dérangé
par une pétarade nous avons appris de
terrible nouvelle est vu des photos
horribles en est bien à guayaquil tous
les cimetières cliniques et hôpitaux
sont saturés
allez dans un cimetière et vous verrez
beaucoup de gens attendre pour enterrer
leurs proches
je pense qu'ils ont au moins résolu le
problème des corps dans les rues au
cours des deux premières semaines les
choses étaient comme ça
ces quinze dernières années il ya eu
beaucoup de privatisation
des ressources publiques ont été
transférés dans des entreprises privées
oui
aujourd'hui avec la menace du
coronavirus une menace nous avons vu que
notre système public n'était pas assez
fort pour y faire face oleg kassine ce
qui est d'accord avec roanne que vie
mais pense que c'est l'ensemble du
système de santé mondiale qui est
corrompu le système de santé modernes
n'était absolument pas prêt tout d'abord
dans les pays qui se considèrent comme
les plus progressistes les pays
développés et c'est tout cela est le
résultat des réformes néolibérales de
ces dernières décennies avec les mises à
la porte des professionnels de la santé
et la commercialisation des soins de la
santé sont en hausse à prêcher dans la
majorité des pays dits développés
le système de santé n'est pas en mesure
de faire face à ce problème
nixon et je pense que c'est une question
cruciale qui a à voir avec le paradigme
de notre civilisation avec notre culture
manaswing lisa ses smashes et pour
l'état
[Musique]
l'un des protagonistes de notre
documentaire sur les survivalistes
américain robert vicino se porte plutôt
bien
ils vont des bunkers où on peut se
terrer en cas de guerre nucléaire ou de
virus les survivalistes ont anticipé une
telle situation
ils ont commencé à se préparer pour la
fin du monde est pour le coup sur le
banc ce qui inquiète les gens ils
peuvent se confiner dans leur maison
n'est ce pas ténu mais imaginons que
cela continue ce qui va arriver c'est
que assez vite les gens qui sont
totalement fauché totalement à court
d'argent
sa prouesse qui n'ont plus de nourriture
dans leur maison pour survivre ont
commencé à piller les magasins
c'est déjà arrivé
les émeutes alimentaires vont commencer
et c'est à ce moment là que les gens
vont commencer à se battre pour tout ce
qu'il ya dans les rayons alors et cela
se produit déjà et les gens ont peur
d'aller travailler au supermarché
alors quelle est l'étape suivante qui
vont commencer à cambrioler les maisons
tour du doigt ils vont devenir violent
et bien robert nous pourrions aussi
parlé des zombies à ce stade elle tape
on est à ce stade
demandez vous à ce que bras comment
vais-je survie alors comment vais-je me
protéger si vous êtes alors quelle
solution à cela tout simplement levé la
quarantaine partout dans le monde
oui ah oui d'accord je pense que oui une
bonne idée à condition d'avoir son
propre bunker mais les statistiques
montrent que les états unis sont dans un
état catastrophique
les etats-unis ont le plus de cas de
coronavirus et de décès dans le monde
des camions frigorifiques ont dit être
envoyés à new york pour stocker les
corps
de la nourriture est distribuée aux
pauvres le maire a ordonné que des
chambres d'hôtel vacante soit utilisé
pour abriter les sans abri mais les
survivalistes sont cyniques
robert ne croit pas à l'altruisme en ces
temps difficiles dans notre cas quelle
est cette solution va des 20 c au
touquet ce que vive hausse le divorce
est un refuge sûr c'est la forteresse
vous pouvez vivre en attendant que tout
cela se termine
jusqu'à ce que ce soit sur le safety car
le gars sera-t-il sûr de sortir parce
que votre image du futur et terrifiante
vous savez ça ne peut pas aller mieux
non non non écouter imaginons que ce
virus réduit vraiment considérablement
la population mondiale d'accord ou
qu'elle se réduisent à cause de ses
conséquences
il y aura des pillards des anarchistes
quoi que ce soit when you can am quand
vous sortirez la nature sera la même
jusqu'à le ciel sera bleu à moins qu'il
ne se passe quelque chose d'autre vous
savez comme une bombe nucléaire
le monde tel que nous le connaissons
attendre à votre liste
j'espère que rien de tel ne se produira
et qu'on va s'en servir pour nous y
opposer
mais si des troubles comme ans ou si
l'état s'effondre nous resterons ici ce
sera notre refuge ici nous survivrons à
cet effondrement
après une conversation comme celle là
j'avais vraiment besoin de parler au
téléphone avec un véritable optimiste
c'est à ce moment là que je me suis
souvenu d'un message que j'avais
récemment reçu du journaliste somare
abou diab il m'avait envoyé un texto
disant qu'il venait de rentrer en syrie
et qu'il allait traverser la pandémie là
bas j'ai de bons souvenirs de mon voyage
en syrie mais de là à y rester pendant
la pandémie
oui je suppose que c'est le plus grand
optimiste de ma liste
ce n'est pas la destination touristique
la plus appréciée au monde mais je
suppose que si nous parlons de la
propagation du coronavirus c'est ce qui
a sauvé la syrie beaucoup de gens
disaient au départ que le gouvernement
syrien avait menti et que l'épidémie
s'était répondu que ce n'était pas dans
les intérêts des autorités d'admettre
que la situation était hors de contrôle
certains pays africains pensent
également que le corona virus n'est pas
arrivé chez eux mais en réalité c'est
qu'ils n'ont tout simplement pas de test
oui oui la syrie à des tests nous les
avons obtenus de l'organisation mondiale
de la santé
je ne pensais pas que ce pays qui était
en guerre depuis 10 ans ce récit
inquiets face aux coronavirus j'étais
aux émirats arabes unis j'ai réussi à
prendre le dernier avion pour la syrie
je suis allé à tartus et soudain cinq
jours plus tard j'ai reçu un appel sur
mon téléphone fixe et on me dit
messieurs somare oui c'est un médecin du
département local de la santé qui vous
parle nous voulons simplement vous
demandez caler votre température si vous
vous sentez bien
quelqu'un a porté plainte contre moi
comme si j'étais une soupe cette
infection en tant que personnes rentrant
de l'étranger si que dieu nous en
préserve le corona virus se propage en
syrie le pays ces fonds n'aura pas ce
que nous n'avons rien nous manquons de
tout je parle de matériel médical les
etats-unis ont mis en place un embargo
très strictes sur la syrie
les entreprises ne peuvent rien apporter
en séries tout contrat mentionnant la
syrie comme destination est annulé le
pays est complètement isolé je considère
cela comme un crime de guerre un crime
humanitaire
voilà après le confinement je t'attends
en syrie pour faire un documentaire
d'accord bien sûr j'ai fait une liste
des endroits où je veux aller après le
confinement
allons en iran virtuellement du moins il
n'était pas facile d'entrer dans ce pays
même avant les restrictions sanitaires
mais je pense que la chose la plus
intéressante est que tous les gens dans
le monde sont dans la même situation
pouvez-vous voyager facilement vers
d'autres pays avec votre passeport
non non c'est impossible
non je ne peux pas c'est toujours un
problème avec lequel je me bats quand je
veux aller à des festivals ou des alors
je sais que c'est parfois assez risqué
on peut me refuser un visa maintenant
j'imagine que peu importe le type de
passeport que vous ayez vous ne fait pas
voler c'est mina est une documentariste
iranienne elle essaie de terminer un
film at on pour sa première mon film
trêve des violences domestiques et des
manquements du système législatif à
travers l'histoire personnelle de ma
grand mère en tant que productrice je
produis aussi un autre film et c'est
bientôt la première prochaine
malheureusement à cause de cette
pandémie
le festival aura lieu en ligne en irons
le gouvernement n'a pas déclaré l'état
d'urgence et malgré un grand nombre de
morts les mesures de confinement n'ont
pas été très strict
en raison de la crise économique et des
problèmes financiers
le gouvernement ne peut prendre aucune
responsabilité ne demande pas
officiellement de tout fermer car ils ne
peuvent pas soutenir les entreprises ils
ne peuvent pas se tenir les employés
vous voyez
l'iran a décidé que les dommages causés
à l'économie par les restrictions
étaient pires que les dommages causés
par le coronavirus déjà sous le coup de
sévères sanctions le pays a été l'un des
premiers à lever le confinement
aujourd'hui c'est le premier jour après
plusieurs journées de confinement tout
est ouvert après les vacances de fin
d'année donc les gens sont au travail si
matt et les rues ne sont plus
silencieuses
une fois de plus des manifestations anti
confinement cette fois en israël le plus
grand rassemblement contre le premier
ministre netanyahu a eu lieu à tel-aviv
les manifestants présents ont maintenu
une distance sociale d'un mètre
cinquante pour éviter d'être accusé de
propager le virus et les entrepreneurs
israéliens ne voulaient absolument rien
avoir à faire avec la distanciation
ils ont exigé que le gouvernement
introduise des mesures d' aide à
l'économie ou leur permettent de rouvrir
leur entreprise
mais à la place selon la journaliste
paul à slayer le confinement en israël a
été prolongée et renforcé je sors dans
la rue avec ma carte de presse
au cas où je serais arrêté par la police
mais je vais seulement vous montrer ce
qu'il se passe ici je vais faire un tour
il est absolument personne sur les
routes alors que c'est l'heure de pointe
je me précipite au studio pour faire un
direct normalement tout cela se fait
dans la panique car je n'ai que quelques
minutes pour tout faire je conduis et en
même temps je parle à moscou de ce qui
doit être inclus dans le direct de
l'actualité la plus récente est parfois
je me maquille c'est donc je suis sur le
point de passer à l'antenne et j'ai aimé
notre presse alors que je vais m'asseoir
rapidement ici les cadreurs me donne une
oreillette et comme vous pouvez le voir
ce moscou m'appelle déjà donc dès que
l'oreillette est en place je serais
prête pour le direct et je vais enlever
cela dans dix secondes afin que je
puisse parlèrent moscou 9 octobre un
score bonjour moscou à l'une des
histoires les plus récentes que paula a
traité concerne le fait qu' israël et
l'administration palestinienne ont été
contraints de collaborer afin de lutter
contre le court-noué un virus
ils travaillent vraiment ensemble où je
rêve je dirais que c'est vrai mais je
dirais compte autant tirer trop de
conclusions car cela ne signifie pas qu
après la fin de la pandémie de
coronavirus ses relations entre
israéliens et gazaouis vont être à
l'origine d'un nouvel avenir commun pas
du tout je pense que les deux parties y
voit une urgence et dans le cadre de
cette urgence nous vous donnerons ce
dont vous avez besoin
malheureusement je pense qu'après ces
mesures d'urgence on reviendra
situation habituellement les juifs
orthodoxes israéliens ne prêtent aucune
attention au confinement
les affrontements entre les juifs
orthodoxes et la police sont courants
c'est ce que nous avons vu ces derniers
jours c'est une augmentation du nombre
d'incidents dans les quartiers religieux
juifs aux unités ont dû patrouiller à
pied et réagir en dispersant les jambes
en parallèle on cherche ce qu'ils ont
déjà passé le test du coronavirus qui
ont eu un résultat positif et on les
vire littéralement de ces quartiers afin
d'empêcher d'autres personnes de tomber
malade donc toute cette panique est dû
au fait que vous essayer d'amener ces
gens à l'hôpital en israël au sein des
communautés ultra religieuses noté juive
et rats religieuse il y à certains
groupes qui sont totalement isolés
nous savons qu'ils ont leurs propres
écoles ne font pas le service militaire
ils n'ont rien à voir avec la société
israélienne
ils grandissent dans un environnement
fermé à l'intérieur de ce quartier
et malheureusement c'est exactement le
quartier sur lequel nous devons nous
concentrer parce qu'ils ne savent pas ce
qui se passe à l'extérieur
le big brother israéliens c'est tout et
surveille tout le monde pendant la
pandémie
les juifs orthodoxes ne sont pas les
seuls à se sentir menacé par cela israël
utilise une technologie qui permet
d'accéder aux informations privées des
gens depuis leur téléphone portable et
boire leurs déplacements ainsi ils
peuvent voir si vous avez croisé une
personne infectée par le coronavirus et
si c'est le cas ils vous envoient
immédiatement un message vous avez
croisé un individu testé positif
merci de vous mettre en confinement chez
vous et quand toute cette pandémie du
coronavirus prendra fin comment pouvez
vous être sûr voilà ce que les gens ont
dit quand nous leur avons parlé dans la
rue comment pouvez vous être sûr que la
police et les autorités ne continueront
pas utiliser ces informations
mais chose intéressante la plupart des
personnes que nous avons rencontrées
la plupart des personnes à qui nous
avons parlé soutiennent réellement cette
initiative
il ya un vrai sentiment de peur ici en
israël vous m'avez demandé ce que ça me
faisait est à vous moi c'est comme si
j'étais dans un cauchemar
oui paul à moi aussi j'ai envie de me
réveiller et que tout cela ne soit qu'un
rêve mais il semble bien que le monde ne
sera plus jamais le même après ce
cauchemar la pandémie a révélé des
problèmes sociaux et économiques
profondément enracinée
les premiers pays à faire face à la
pandémie ont été les premiers à
assouplir les mesures de confinement
[Musique]
je me suis éloigné du réfrigérateur pour
qu'ils arrêtent de m'empêcher de
travailler
j'ai appelé en italie
[Musique]
les italiens ont dépensé 19 % de plus
sans nourriture pendant le confinement
par rapport à la même période l'année
dernière
malheureusement c'est là le seul point
positif pour l'économie
l'italie a été le premier pays européen
à introduire le confinement
même s'ils pourraient être levés sous
peu selon le gouvernement de nombreuses
entreprises rouvriront leurs portes
mais les masques élégant resteront
obligatoires svetlana allège cov kaya a
décidé de se rappeler ces cours
d'ateliers et s'est mise à la machine à
coudre
[Musique]
ici en loup mardi quand les gens seront
autorisés à sortir et seront tenus de
mettre ces masques pendant un certain
temps ce que tu fais j'espère c'est de
la haute couture non ma fille m'a
demandé de coudre un masque à paillettes
elle n'est pas encore fait
je vais essayer d'en faire un full spec
l'anah avait récemment changé de travail
et commencer une carrière dont le
tourisme
c'était le pire moment possible cette
industrie a été touché en premier dès
que les vols ont été annulés les
frontières fermées
je pense que ça nous a touchés avant
tout le monde
nous continuons à recevoir de salaire
mais combien de temps ça va durer
nous devons être prêts à tout le
gouvernement italien versatile des
compensations tu sais je travaille pour
la suisse et le gouvernement suisse a
soutenu et à aider les entreprises en
italie cela fait toujours l'objet de
discussions c'est parce qu'il faut plus
de temps à l'union européenne pour
coordonner ces choses je suppose
j'ai un appel de l'espagne esteban est
un journaliste espagnol qui passe la
plupart de son temps confinés à repérer
des faits que nous est-il vrai que les
policiers espagnols traînent dans les
rues et chante en jouant de la guitare
c'est la plus belle chose de tout ils le
font tous les jours dans une heure si
vous m'appelez dans une heure vous
pourrez entendre les gens applaudir il y
a beaucoup de choses qui se passe en ce
moment nous sommes 40 millions dans ce
pays
vous pouvez trouver toutes ces belles
images de gens qui s'amusent sur les
balcons en chantant mais d'un autre côté
il y à beaucoup de gens il ya beaucoup
de violence domestique de plus en plus
le gouvernement a des outils pour aider
toutes ces femmes
je veux dire toutes celles qui sont
victimes d'agression au couteau qui sont
blessés ce n'est qu'un exemple je
continue à travailler
je travaille jusqu'à 5 heures du matin
je regarde l'heure et je me dis quoi il
est 5 heures du matin vraiment
à l'apogée de la pandémie ma collègue de
france est isolée chez elle et a créé
une page facebook intitulée mouse trap
mimos
il s'agit de trois de ses amis qui ont
été coincés avec leur ex mari pendant le
confinement
je connais une fille pour elle ça a été
une sacrée histoire elle était séparée
d'avec lui
divorcée ensuite ses parents leur ont
proposé de rester chez eux pendant le
confinement qu'union un cauchemar irina
dit que c'est mouse trap semaine ans
sont de plus en plus populaire à mesure
que l'épidémie se poursuit nasa en fait
je pense qu'il ya quelque chose qui
ressort chez ces gens du pétrole ils
sont sous le choc ce matin
voilà à quoi ressemble l'indignation à
la française ces manifestants sont en
colère contre la police locale pour
avoir fait tomber un motocycliste de sa
moto en le poursuivant pour avoir
enfreint des mesures de confinement
le jeune homme est décédé un cas
similaire en belgique voisine a
également provoqué une vague de
violences une de mes amies m'a récemment
envoyé un texto irina c'est terrible
hier 600 personnes sont mortes dans les
maisons de retraite puis un autre ami
m'a dit mais non c'est pas six ans et
400 accès seulement 4/100 et les gens se
réjouissait 200 personnes de moins mais
les chiffres sont terrifiants quand on y
pense c'est une sorte de mécanisme
psychologique de défense
haïk vardanyan un médecin français de
l'unité de soins intensifs analyse sur
instagram la lutte contre le virus
depuis le début de l'épidémie
nous lui avons demandé ce qu'il pensait
de tout cela plus de 2000 personnes sont
décédées dans des maisons de retraite
la vague ne s'arrêtait pas nous devions
prendre des décisions rapides
un tube et réanimé et c'est une unité de
soins intensifs de 10 lits est devenue
une unité intensif de 36 lits en une
semaine
il n'y avait rien eu de tel auparavant
les 36 patients sont souvent filateurs
chef il ne s'agit pas d'une grippe ou
d'une infection virale vague
cette maladie est totalement différente
même si les symptômes sont similaires
température légèrement plus élevé tout
et c'est la maladie est totalement
différente
c'est imprévisible nous avons renvoyé à
un homme
après quatre jours d'hospitalisation le
lendemain il a eu des complications
nous avons réussi alain tubes et qu'il
est aux soins intensifs maintenant mais
les pronostics sont mauvais nous venons
de ranimer les premiers patients intubés
tout le monde est venu c'est tellement
touchant tellement touchant je vous
souhaite tellement heureux bravo bravo
[Applaudissements]
le narrateur de rt david watson qui vit
en russie est retourné au royaume uni
pour soutenir sa mère âgée après le vol
il s'est confiné deux semaines
une bactérie mois newsweek ceux qui
regardent les documentaires de rt en
anglais reconnaîtront probablement ma
voix est maintenant qu ils m'ont vu ils
comprendront pourquoi je ne fais que le
doublage et c'est tout encore un
programme terminé vous savez ce qui est
absolument le pire dans l'isolément et
le confinement
qu'est ce que c'est j'ai terriblement
besoin d'aller chez le coiffeur
quand tout sera fini je ressemblerais un
nid d'oiseau on est non tu ressemblera à
une rock-star voit le bon côté des
choses
oui d'accord alyssa j'aime bien que fais
tu de ta journée user et bien
étrangement je suis j'ai l'impression
d'être plus occupée depuis le début du
confinement que je ne l'étais au bureau
et je suis très chanceux d'avoir le
logiciel spécifique dont j'ai besoin
pour générer des sous titres et bien sûr
j'ai l'équipement audio pour enregistrer
narration et voix
[Musique]
et voilà comment est ma vie en
angleterre en ce moment comme dans la
plupart des pays la pandémie à détourner
l'attention du public de sujets
scandaleux et a complètement changé le
contenu des informations au royaume-uni
que j'ai aidé notre équipe qui tournait
un film sur le scandale du sang
contaminé en amérique en grande bretagne
en europe
ç'avait été un scandale mondial dit si
ça avait été un très gros problème
il y avait de nouveau médicament
fabriqué à partir de sang contaminé
ce sont venus de prisonniers américains
par exemple ils étaient contaminés par
le vih et l'hépatite et dans ce film
nous avons interviewé un homme jason
event's fin dont le père est décédé
quand il était petit je lui à nouveau
parler la semaine dernière après le
début du confinement
nous avons discuté de la façon dont la
campagne l'anc est et sa situation
personnelle ont été affectés par le
contexte
je suppose que tout s'est arrêté à cause
du corona virus le coronavirus a pour
l'instant mis un terme à l' enquête une
croix riccione n 7 en pause
provisoirement jusqu'en septembre
matière tabac est en effet si on reste
enfermé pendant encore quelques mois
mais quand la fin il n'en restera que
quelques centaines pour nous donc encore
moins de personnes bénéficieront
directement de l' enquête pour trouver
quoi quand le confinement sera levé
beaucoup de problèmes qui nous semblait
très important feront déjà partie du
passé
cela permet de voir sa vie sous un autre
angle n'est ce pas mais si cela vous
fait prendre conscience de ce qui est
important et de ce qu'il est mon
à belgrade un couvre feu a été mis en
place le journaliste serbe vlada nhra
d'ojika raconte que si 95% des personnes
respectent ces restrictions
5% ne le font pas il ya quelques jours
des arrestations ont eu lieu dans
l'hôtel le plus populaire de belgrade et
une vingtaine de personnes ont été
arrêtées les gens considéraient l'hôtel
comme une solution car les bars et les
restaurants étaient fermés partout sauf
dans ce grand hôtel
vous savez notre gouvernement a déclaré
l'état d'urgence et c'est une bonne
décision le 15 mars ou même avant les
autres régions les frontières ont été
fermées immédiatement après suffit il me
quelque chose où tu es aussi confiné
tout journaliste à condition qu'ils
soient d'enregistrer obtient une
autorisation afin qu'ils puissent
travailler
je ne sais pas si vous avez entendu mais
un avion d'aidé humanitaire russe est
arrivé il ya quelques jours nous avons
fait la couverture complète de ce sujet
je laisse 2 comment le personnel médical
et les autorités se sont ils préparés à
la pandémie
je t'ai entendu parler d'un stade où
d'une salle qui avait été converti en
chasse et bien c'est un hôpital
temporaire l'armée il ya installé de
nombreux lits et équipements
c'est principalement pour les gens qui
se sentent relativement bien mais qui
ont été testés positifs au coronavirus
ces gens là seront admis dans les
grandes salles de sport passons à une
partie du monde surpeuplé où le
confinement n'est pas une option
ici les gens ont plus peur de la famine
que du virus
la capitale des philippines manille
compte plus de 25 millions d'habitants
dont la plupart vivent dans des
bidonvilles
le président philippin rodrigo dutertre
que nous avons interrogés il y à peu sur
ses méthodes violentes de lutte contre
le trafic de drogue a de nouveau fait la
une des journaux
il menace désormais de donner à la
police la permission de tirer et de tuer
les contrevenants aux mesures de
confinement et les philippins savent que
ce n'est pas une blague
il ya des pauvres qui ont pu poser des
problèmes alors le président a déclaré
si vous semer le chaos dans notre pays à
cause de cette pandémie
vous profitez donc de la pandémie alors
je demanderai à mes militaire et à la
police de vous tirer dessus ou de vous
tuer alors sur la page facebook j'ai
déjà eu des messages concernant deux
meurtres
c'est une situation très difficile pour
les habitants des bidonvilles que nous
avons filmé pour nos documentaires
tu te souviens deux probablement c'est
l'un des problèmes pour les autorités
nourrir toutes ces personnes et en même
temps leur donner un revenu en ce moment
le gouvernement en plus de donner de la
nourriture de temps en temps à chaque
ménage fournit aussi des aides en
espèces aux familles pauvres
et voilà la ville d'argelès où la
majeure partie de la population vit du
tourisme sexuel
voici à quoi ressemble la 3eme avenue et
le soir elle est totalement fermé en ce
moment en raison de la pandémie de kobe
de 19
une preuve directe que l'on te mets vous
de la nourriture à ce moment surtout en
cette période de crise nous avons stocké
de conserve
mais parfois mes frères et soeurs n'en
veulent plus j'arrive sans mange tous
les jours
du coup je les fais cuire déjà joutes
les légumes l'aide du gouvernement est
elle suffisante pour subvenir aux
besoins de votre famille sur ton à ce
moment difficile
ça suffit pour tenir une journée mais si
le confinement continue pendant encore
un mois
cela ne suffira pas surtout que j'ai
beaucoup de frères et soeurs
combien de frères et soeurs avez-vous si
si ils mettent en place un nouveau point
de contrôle
pour tous ceux qui entre le camion
est ce dangereux de sortir pour toi avez
vous un permis spécial au yacht pour
sortir il faut avoir saab et johan faut
avoir cette carte d'identité avec une
photo elle vous permet de couvrir la
pandémie et vous devez avoir ce
laissez-passer pour sortir de chez vous
si vous ne l'avez pas eh ben la police
vous arrêtera au point de contrôle c'est
l'aéroport de manille presque vide à
midi 440 marins ont été renvoyés chez
eux il y a eu un vol affrété de madrid
vers les philippines ces marins iront
donc en quarantaine avant de rejoindre
leur famille après ça nous sommes allés
à l'église à l'église de bakara
le prêtres les religieuses et les
volontaires préparer des repas pour ceux
qui sont en première ligne et en même
temps pour les sans abri la pandémie a
touché tant de personnes en particulier
les personnes marginalisées
c'est très triste là nous rentrons chez
nous il n'y a pas de circulation dans la
rue et c'est la pleine lune
j'espère que cette pandémie se terminera
bientôt je suis celle d'abyane dacca
l'agneau des philippines merci natalia
mais il y à des endroits sur terre où la
pratique de la distance sociale est
impossible les camps de réfugiés sont
devenus une bombe à retardement
voici le camp gros india
ces images ont été fournies par sayed un
réfugié qui vit ici depuis plus de deux
ans pour certains cet endroit et leur
maison depuis plus d'une décennie
[Musique]
comment ça va as tu un travail
comment survit tu bref comment va ta
famille oui ils vont bien ils vont bien
je travaille comme traducteur ged avec
ça et tu retournes en birmanie ou non si
si j'aimerais bien retourner en birmanie
[Musique]
les camps de réfugiés sont interdits car
ils constituent un environnement idéal
pour la propagation de toute sorte
d'épidémie
un million de personnes vivent sur cette
parcelle de terre dans les camps de
réfugiés de cox bazar
en outre le bangladesh lui même à la
densité de population la plus élevée au
monde avec ses 170 millions d'habitants
dacca n'est pas une très grande ville
les plus de 20 millions d'habitants y
vit un grand nombre de résidents ne sont
pas originaires de dacca mais ils
viennent pour travailler il reste comme
moi je suis aussi pigiste du 26 mars au
4 avril le gouvernement a déclaré des
jours fériés des gants mais récemment de
nombreux ouvriers du textile ont
commencé à venir de 110 120 km de dacca
alors ils sont venus à dacca et le
lendemain matin on leur a dit oh les
usines restent fermées
la mise en place du confinement en inde
s'est avéré être une mission impossible
comment isoler un milliard trois cent
cinquante sept millions de personnes
si la chine est une population similaire
la densité de population en inde est
trois fois plus élevé maudit a déclaré
21 jours de confinement à cause du
coronavirus après cela de nombreux
employés du textile ont perdu leur
emploi ils n'ont pas d'argent pour
survivre et ils n'ont pas d'argent pour
rentrer chez eux
c'est pourquoi ils manifestent dans la
rue de sourds ac
la police a dû intervenir après la levée
du confinement
la plupart des migrants n'ont pas eu
d'offres d'emploi et les corps nous
avons souhaité offrir aux tec avant la
pandémie habituellement la plupart des
gens étaient recrutés sur les bords de
la route
maintenant ce n'est plus possible en
chaîne c'est pourquoi il y à des
travailleurs qui sont repartis avec leur
famille et là des gens sont aussi morts
sur le bord de la route
me john
bonjour natacha cette voiture tu en
penses quoi
c'est la voiture du corps un un virus
c'est pour la chaîne documentaire rt
c'est une vraie voiture avec sireau et
un moteur et elle peut aller jusqu'à 40
km heure avec cette voiture nous voulons
envoyer un message clair aux gens
insisté sur le fait que le coronavirus
est dangereux ce qu'il faut rester à la
maison
restez chez vous
[Musique]
et voici les ornithologues de notre film
sur les animaux sauvages en russie ils
passent tous les ans l'hiver en inde
pour rédiger des articles universitaires
et étudier les oiseaux comme des
milliers d'autres russe ils se sont
retrouvés coincés à goa à cause de
l'annulation soudaine de vol car les
frontières avait fermé la vie s'est
arrêtée avant c'était une route très
fréquentée
regarder des gens qui enfreignent le
confinement c'est comme ça depuis près
d'un mois
j'avais au bord de la mer ou dans la
montagne et je regarde les oiseaux les
coupures de courant sont fréquentes ici
et il n'y a pas de réseau je ne peux pas
travailler sur mon ordinateur et en
russie l'activité est suspendue
ici il y à internet mais pas en bas
c'est insoluble il faut monter ici pour
avoir du réseau
parce que sans le réseau vous ne pouvez
rien faire même pas obtenir un
laissez-passer électronique
je peux vivre comme ça mais certains
projets sont tombés à l'eau en raison de
ses mesures de confinement
les états sont fermés un oiseau que nous
suivons avec une balise a quitté goa
pour marc c'est impossible d'y aller
alors on reste ici en regardant les
derniers oiseaux partir vers la maison
en profitant du soleil et de la mer
quand il dort a vraiment commencé à
envisager une randonnée à travers le
népal il a réussi à acheter des billets
pour un vol vers la russie
un simple film ne peut pas inclure les
caractéristiques particulières du
confinement dans chaque pays
mais ces producteurs sont impatients de
le diffuser car ils espèrent du fond du
coeur que cette pandémie va bientôt
s'achever et que le sujet aura perdu
toute pertinence
nous voilà dans l'avion
j'aime tout bien désinfecter